Iraqi Kurdistan's independence
referendum may seem like the culmination
of a century long dream. If it were to
happen, the outcome would be clear. But
why is the United States and the
international community so opposed? The
problem is determining what is Kurdistan.
The world recognizes Erbil, Sulaymaniyah,  and
Dohuk as Kurdish, but the referendum
includes other areas claimed by the
Iraqis. That means an immediate fight
over borders. Then there's the economy.
Kurdistan is twenty billion dollars in
debt. It has less oil than the rest of
Iraq, and landlocked, it would be at its
neighbors mercy. After independence, it
will not only lose its 17 percent claim
to Iraq's revenues, but Baghdad will also
demand it pay a share of Iraq's debt.
Simply put, it's not going to be able to
pay its teachers, soldiers, and
bureaucrats. The biggest problem will be
its neighbors. Both Turkey and Iran fear
the precedent independence would have
upon their own Kurdish minorities. Iran
can destabilize its new neighbor, and
Turkey can send in troops. Political
divisions among the Kurdish Peshmerga
further undermine hope for stability. So
here's the question for Washington:
Americans might sympathize with Kurdish aspirations, but will America fund and fight for them?
To learn more about my
take on Kurdistan and Kurdish issues,
check the links in the description below.
And if you enjoyed the video, be sure to
like and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI.